pour ces enfants c'est devenu la
nouvelle sortie du week end à dijon de
bibliothèques municipales sont désormais
ouvertes le premier dimanche après midi
du mois et les lecteurs sont au rendez
vous il ya beaucoup de livres pour les
enfants pour les jeux pour les plus
grands et j'aime bien les gens qui sont
ici sont gentils tout ça et dans cette
bibliothèque jeunesse les histoires se
racontent le plus souvent en famille
l'allée du gilenya en est nouveau sur
dijon mais c'était très pratique du
court aux chercheurs des activités parce
qu'ils bougent et donc avoir la
bibliothèque
c'était super vraiment c'est intéressant
parce que moi je travaille la semaine le
samedi souvent court partout vous fait
dimanche est parfait les filles adorent
les livres les la semaine est libre mais
sans moi donc ça me permet de profiter
pour la municipalité l'objectif c'est de
rendre la culture encore plus accessible
et d'après elle ça marche
les mois précédents les deux
bibliothèques ont attiré 300 lecteurs le
dimanche après midi et nous avions
surtout ce qui nous a interpellé 25 % de
nouveaux lecteurs ou de personnes
nouvelles qui venait dans notre
bibliothèque ce qui pour nous était
intéressant ça veut dire que nous avons
réussi à toucher avec cette ouverture là
les personnes qui ne venaient pas dans
les prochains mois d'autres
bibliothèques à dijon ouvriront aussi
certains dimanche il y aura même des
animations avec des associations et le
tout bien sûr reste gratuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]